question for about two characters i'm
curious to know if you have anything to
say about this one is johnny russo one
is john a light both of them have been
on valuetainment both of them have
gotten millions of views john a light
you know he's you know especially right
now with the interview taking place
mafia states of america there's a lot of
people making videos
they're happy some are not happy some
are calling you out some are calling
michael out there's a lot some are
calling sammy out
what what what what can you say from
your experience you guys were both in
the is it rip city new york uh i don't
know what that document is
both of you guys were rip cities you
know i'm thinking about uh
yeah trail blazers so what what what is
your point of view of
john aylett everywhere i go when i run
into albanians they adore they admire
him what can you say about john
patrick i never met the guy
i never heard of the guy i never knew
anything about him until he came up on
social media for some reason he decided
to make comments about me
um again i don't know anybody that knew
him i don't know anything about him
and i've always said to myself i'm not
gonna i'm not gonna make my name by
knocking other people
i'm gonna leave it at that i have really
nothing to say about him
how about gianni how about johnny russo
johnny rousseau
i mean he's almost a comedy act i mean
this guy has done everything in in the
history of the united states and beyond
i never met him either i don't know
anything about him he says a lot of
things that happened you know during the
making of the godfather i was around i
never seen him i'm not saying he didn't
show up
but i think a lot of the things that
he's saying are just uh he's an actor
what more can i say
i mean some of the stories it's just
it's by the way another great
storyteller of what he's yeah i'm
unfamiliar like
he said something about to go watch it
like saddam hussein he sat in the same
church saddam hussein stuff he did with
the shah uh
stuff and by the way the way he tells a
story it's so detailed that's like
you know it's extremely detailed on how
he tells i told him when i sat down with
him i said johnny first of all i enjoy
being around you because you're so
entertaining i said but if ten percent
of the stories you're telling me is true
you'll live the ridiculous life
is the mafia forest gump is that the he
said one story about joe colombo blowing
up the gates of paramount studios and
that would be huge news i never heard
that happen ever you know and i was
around during the whole colombo
godfather thing you know when it was
being i never heard any of that spoke
very highly of your props very highly of
your problem you know who he was and you
know what he had to say i doubt my
father ever met him so if you enjoyed
this little short segment from the
podcast that we did here's another short
segment to watch or if you want to see
the entire podcast click over here take
care everybody bye
[Music]